we might be drunk we
might be drunk as long as we
are hanging out you know we might be
drunk
raise a glass let's talk [ __ ] head peeps
wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk we might be
drunk yeah
hey folks here we are
we might be drunk and it's the middle of
the day and we're about to put down
some hooch it's hard to find time to
make this work we're both on the road
three travel days in a row for me i know
i saw you we did a patreon get on it
folks
and uh you were yacked on a on a
cross-country flight i
just thought i just thrown up nice you
farted
like if you're playing the mark farts at
home drinking game
drink up oh yeah yeah you just thrown up
oh cross country flight with the mask on
too you're like i smell my
awful vomit breath oh god uh yeah
it's hilarious i'm on the phone my mom
and she and she's like just do not drink
alcohol and i'm just like i'm on all
fours
you think i got a gimlet handy like i'm
dying
jesus christ who am i hemingway puking
here
yeah yeah that's mom's for you she
always gives you advice that is
completely obvious oh my god it's not
it's
uh she's literally not doing a character
ends every call with uh
drink your drink uh take your vitamins
and
uh floss yeah you know it's a mom thing
that you know we should call that as
momsplaining
you know like don't touch the dead
pigeon don't drink alcohol while you're
food poisoning you're like yeah i got it
mom
mom's planning is good it is uh flossing
like
it's just moms yeah that's just who's
telling you to floss
i i have a i think flossing is a little
bit of a racket
do you think so well i floss i used to
go to the i used to have braces for six
years i go to the dentist it's all six
years
oh it was a nightmare i was a [ __ ] up
kid the bedwetting the dandruff the
neighborhood
the whole thing but uh i you know he's
like you gotta floss you gotta floss and
you see all these commercials
dental what do you call it gum disease
gingivitis listerine
i floss maybe once a month and there's
nothing in there
really i go in i got the stick i got the
like the little
you know it's like a hook with the floss
thing in it yeah that was a great
invention like you're getting pulled off
with the apollo but in your mouth yeah
exactly no yeah i i hate those things
it's just not it's not fun no it's not
fun but if you get a big chunk of
grizzle you're like oh wow that wasn't
necessary but i'm doing it and i'm
getting nothing
yeah it's pretty annoying and then you
get the times when you bleed and you're
just like i guess i gotta do this
what am i a virgin yeah that's brutal
i know but it's necessary but i don't
think it's people say you gotta do it
like every day or every other day and i
don't think it's true
yeah i don't know but then there's all
these people saying that like it helps
with gum disease and so much of disease
come through like not flossing i don't
think that i know who knows
who knows yeah i guess it's better to do
it but like when people when you're
young and people like you gotta floss
you're like
i don't even remember getting home you
think i'm gonna remember to floss yeah
good point
i didn't brush good point good point i
think a lot of that is uh hearsay
the uh it's a wives tale don't eat don't
swim when you're hungry i've eaten a
buffet and i hit the beach
i've never done any of that [ __ ] i eat
when i'm i've i mean i've swim when i've
been eating like a [ __ ] full cake
your new balance game look at these oh
thank you look at that you this is like
what a dad who has money wears it's like
a shiny new balance these were given to
me i would never buy these they're too
hip but the black folk
love these do they yeah yeah i've been
chased
i got and i got like dad shoes on too
look at these they're like dad runners
oh yeah these shoes have come a long way
they're so colorful now
chooses to be white and black and maybe
gray and now look at that it's blue and
blue and orange blue and orange yeah
yeah and you got that and you got like
leather
sneakers i know they're crazy what are
we drinking these are my show shoes i
only wear them when i'm performing
show shoes who
remember when he told us that we were
like young comics he goes these are my
show shoes and we're like show shoes
yeah well it's not like these aren't
special but i don't want to break i
don't want to wear them out because
they're so
cool i guess so i only wear them on
stage yeah that makes sense
it's more of a all right guinness
nothing like an ice cold bottle of the
gin
i love it i love what was the other you
said you brought a backup option i want
the guinness but i want to know what
else you brought i got some fosters
because it's a hot day something
something fun this feels like a day beer
to me
i'm gonna i'm more of a guinness man
than a foster's man
uh yeah it's not the best beer and then
i got just a corona
familiar i've never even heard of it i
haven't either
familiar i'm not familiar
what what are they i thought it was
extra light
and now we're familiar i think it's like
the banquet of corona
um so look at that oh you got it on your
keychain
oh yeah come on i'm an alcoholic
it's funny that when i that's on my car
key too so i just have a bottle opener
dangling for my ignition
i saw uh i saw paul verzi all things
comedy posted thing our buddy paul versi
was defending white claw kind of like we
did i saw that
and then every comment was just like
this guy's an alcoholic like
every defense is like oh put you [ __ ]
[ __ ] on your ass i
drink a lot and then everyone's like
this guy's yeah oh you this
is a bad porn poor
i love a black and tan underrated drink
what is it what is that a yingling and a
guinness or what happened
i thought it was a michelob wait what is
it it's got some ramen no i'm thinking
of a dark and stormy
darkened storm is pretty good too yeah
what is a black and tan
damn we haven't really experimented with
weird cocktails on this we trying to we
kind of should
well we don't really have a bar here we
got it maybe we got to make a bar here
we got to get a bar and
by the way i i love in this studio
there's a security guard i've never seen
them stopping
i know there's a guy in the lobby he's
literally watching a show without
headphones in
yeah and i just walk out like i'm like
this no this dude's why is he here
i know they're paying a guy that could
be the booze uh
oh yeah right there yeah that's true
best gig in town though he just sits
there watching tv on the clock
he's never stopped me he always goes hey
what's up i'm coming with two bags of
booze he's like get in there
if you walk in confidently you can get
into most places that's true yeah
that's true if you kind of go well
looking for a
then they don't like you they got to
sign in and you got to give a name and a
number
but yeah confident how do they know is
that is that white privilege
or is that just fake it till you make it
fake it till you make it yeah
i think i think you're really privileged
he's black so
that means he's uh he's giving in to
white privilege
just like just like a white person to
make it their fault
yeah they're ruining the country let's
let's take a sip of this here cheers
it looks like a milk hey to hitler's
good ideas
hey the guy great tasting clothing
no i really i have an issue because it's
i i obviously you know jew
but you know my neighborhood there's
stumptown coffee is so good and they
gave money to the nazis it really is
it's a real problem
i didn't know that really upsets me
volkswagen hugo boss
yeah all nazi bmw bmw
that one makes sense you're like yeah
you look at the logo you're like that
feels nazi
it does it has a swastika kind of vibe
but who loves bmws
jews yeah i love stumptown coffee
you have one i have my car that old car
is a beamer
and it's an old beamer too so it
probably has some bad ideas still
oh [ __ ] i didn't realize that it's got
that uh new car smell and that old
hitler smell in there
it's a little gassy all right
but yeah oh [ __ ] dude the whole thing it
was a whole article now like
i forgot some there's some
american institution using uh gassing
people to death like for lethal
uh execution oh wow and uh i could have
just said
execution i don't know if we need a
lethal in there but uh
but they're like this is how this is
what the nazis did they're saying yeah
that's how they did it and you're like
well what is murdering someone do you
really care how they it's like that's a
good point
it's a good point yeah like i guess
there's a classier way to get
executed i don't know well you don't
want to hang either yeah that's true
that's got some history and it's just so
barbaric or whatever you want to call it
people would watch
yeah it's so horrible uh isn't that
weird that people would just
watch you get [ __ ] murdered that was
like the town would be like all right
it was pre-internet you know i was like
hey this is hanging it too it's
something to do it was like seeing a
guitar act
in central park you know i i think too
someone's dying in public yeah it's like
uh you know we all watched this
faces of death you knew it was bad are
you you're driving by your rubber neck
oh there's a guy in a body bag you know
we all have to look and i think it's
it's kind of part of that
yeah also
i think firing squad is the classiest is
it i think we should bring that back
they put the blindfold you get the
cigarette it's got some dignity to it
and they all put their guns up and they
only have one bullet i think i feel like
they use that a lot in wars though i
feel like it's got kind of like a
barbaric feeling that's true
that's true i guess lethal injection is
the
is the move that's probably the move
that's the most
am i getting the covert vaccine am i
getting murdered it's got the same feel
it's kind of weird
murderna yeah that's true
uh you remember that george carlin bit
we're so obsessed with like
health and germs he's like we swab your
arm before we give you the lethal
objections
that's so good so good what a great
little catch
yeah you don't need a shower every day
folks i saw our buddy wayne fetterman
oh fallon the other day and he was
plugging a book on the history of
standard but it looks great
it looks really great did you watch the
history of late night on cnn
it just came out no i watched one on uh
you know i thought i saw clips of it i
think i was in it for a second
i think he might have been actually i
think so yeah cause jessica pilot sent
me a
i think you're at the seller no i'm on i
think i'm on colbert in it she sent me a
thing of it
it's like me walking out an ill-fitting
suit in a shitty haircut oh yes
yes yeah you got that was back when i
didn't know suits could fit
that was a you know we were a newer com
it was like our funeral suit or weddings
it was it was it was it was a
multi-purpose suit it's funny when you
watch comics in the 90s
anyone in the 90s you're like man you
just looked you could be out of shape
yeah and like like that was a nice like
gary shanley is wearing like a giant
42 long double brush but it's armani and
he looked good
exactly it's so true yeah the suit thing
we're such children because i didn't buy
a real suit till
till the seinfeld opening because i knew
he would pick it apart i knew he's such
a psycho he'd be like what the [ __ ] is
this suit you got to get a real suit
that was i was 36 bought a suit
yeah i don't think i got a good one
until uh
i did i bought a cool one for fallon oh
there's something
it's late night i should i've worn suits
on fallon and colbert just because i
feel like they're like
they they appreciate and i'm like they
always say they appreciate it when you
wear a suit i'm like you think jimmy
fallon gives a [ __ ]
show up in a wife beater yeah meanwhile
there's these younger kids with like
leather jackets and all this [ __ ]
like torn jeans and i'm like what the
hell are we doing
i do it is but we do look weird
i remember burke crystal once said to me
he's like you don't look good in a suit
he's like what are you doing he's like
you're not a suit guy well
i think he saw me in the one that didn't
fit i see yeah no
if we get one that fits it looks all
right yeah anyone looks good any guy
looks good in a sharp suit but that one
with no
tie though tonight's show on do you look
badass thanks did the open
white collar that's a good look that's a
good blue suit
yeah and pete lee looks good in a suit
he always drops money on suits so
every time you see pete least valence
sets he's like
he told me a story that he went to
bloomingdale's and he was like oh this
is so expensive this suit and they're
like
he's like i'm wearing it on fallon can
you do anything for me to like
come this way there's like a [ __ ]
special what i think he got like half
off because he said he was going to wear
it on tv
jeez you know who didn't have that was
men's warehouse
that's where i got mine you got yours
you got your seinfeld no no my other one
my other one before that
before that like we tailor it right here
i was like oh my god
you're nothing wrong with men's
warehouse but like it's jerry you gotta
i got mine i got mine at that place suit
supply that's where i got the jerry one
you know what's great because it's just
the whole thing is like it fits
that's the whole thing is like we'll
make it fit yes yes and the dudes who
are wearing suits in there they look
great so they know what they're doing
yeah it's kind of a good look the suit
is it just will never go out of style
but
it's funny like you look at even like i
saw a sex in the city episode it's like
mr big
is supposed to be like this cool rich
guy i'm like that suit looks like [ __ ] i
know but i know that's like
probably a really expensive suit it's a
time yeah
it's also funny too if somebody was
making fun of 80s comics like what's
with the sport coat they all look so
cheesy i'm like we all wear bombers
it's the same thing it's just a
different era you know we all wear the
same jacket
yeah sometimes i see a jacket and i'm
like man
i can't it's funny like i was i did a
riff the other night on stage about like
somehow someone started heckling about
the royal family so i started [ __ ]
on them like like
my angle was like who the [ __ ] do you
think you are like wearing a crown like
i'm embarrassed
by certain jackets you know what i mean
like it's true that's
part of the thing i was like man don't
you ever put on like a blazer and you're
like i haven't earned it
no dude all the time and i like them
they look cool especially like a summer
blades i see a guy with like a
like a seersucker a seersucker you like
that i love it or linen or something and
i'm like this guy's got cool frames and
a t-shirt on
under the sears so i'm like oh what a
badass like harry hamlin on mad men or
something
he's got no socks with the loafers and
he's drinking a manhattan in the sun i'm
like this
guy's a badass he's on a boat or a pier
yeah but i can't do it
yeah i can't do it either i try i've
even bought them and i just don't wear
them
they're just hanging in my closet like i
didn't see i bought some cole haan
sneakers they're these beautiful brown
leather i've never worn them
you're wearing for like a cool gig or
something i get it they were 300 bucks i
was like i'm wearing these i
wear the same thing i got these cool
loafers like that that are like the same
price like super expensive and then
like i in the store i'm like [ __ ] yeah i
look cool
and then i put them on i'm like i'm
gonna get torn apart for these i can't
do it
i just picture what like keith robinson
or colin quinn would say if they saw me
in those
totally totally and you're killing in
the mirror at the store and then you
just
yeah because you're in front of a guy
who's trying to get a friend
commissioned right
he's like yeah this works for you you
don't know me yes
i know ah brutal what is that in turn
because not everyone has that
other people go the other way they go
i'm the man i look great i'm wearing
this every day
self-loathing i guess so like it's just
a
this is a good day drink a guinness it
works dude um
yeah you need a hand because whenever
you meet someone they don't have
i mean we we those people that are just
sure themselves we [ __ ] hate them
yeah yeah i think jim jeffries has a
great bit about how like
uh low self-esteem is actually like a
great quality
because imagine if you had high
self-esteem and you're you're building a
car
yes i don't think it's gonna work ah
it's gonna work because i did it then
the guy
flies off the highway or something yeah
then and then you've got the asian guy
who goes by like
he's being really careful he's like
that's who you want making your car
that's a great bet
great bit great fit jay leno always says
low self-esteem is a good quality
yeah because you you worry about things
i mean it's hell for us because we're in
the middle of it and we have anxiety and
we're freaking out but
i think you'll make a better product you
don't hate yourself but uh you have like
a hint of it
yeah yeah you want it to go well you're
worried about the judgment you're
worried about it sucking
yeah i mean a dude who shows up in a
fedora you're like you didn't have that
moment where you looked in the mirror
and we're like
maybe not yeah i don't know yes you want
that minute even if you go even if
you're like i'm i'm doing a fedora day
you want a minute where you're like i'm
not sure yes
self-doubt i wouldn't even say
self-loathing self-doubt maybe
self-awareness yes exactly exactly and
like my girl
i list one thing i love about her she
hates any guy trying to be sexy like in
a photo like a guy like
she's like oh that's a [ __ ] yeah even
if you're hot it's like
yes even if you're hot and if you're uh
like trying like your outfit you know
you got the shirt buttoned down
and even if you are hot she's like
you're trying to be hot well how do you
feel what if a woman posts pictures like
that trying to be hot
i love it i mean well i'm not a it's a
lady thing but
i think she's right because as a guy
that's a weird
weird personality it's weird to be into
your looks as a dude
yes that's what it is the guy's staring
in the mirror he's not
doing this [ __ ] like you know slicking
back the hair all that
[ __ ] is rough yeah yeah that's like
every
i feel like uh every tom cruise movie
like the opening is a scene where he's
just like looking in the mirror smiling
yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] i know i know but
then
some girls like that yeah well clearly i
mean that
they haven't stopped doing that it's
working yeah i mean every
all the bullies in high school tough
guys my high school mean [ __ ] guys
they had the hottest girlfriends all the
time and look it's high school so these
are dumb guys and dumb girls but
guess what a lot of those dumb people uh
you get to be an adult and uh they're
still around and kicking
i know i know they're on wall street or
whatever the hell
they're doing fine but so it's you got
to meet the right kill
yeah i do there's something about a suit
though like i wish i was a suit guy but
i'm also glad i'm not it's a lot of
upkeep
a lot of dry cleaning bills yeah a lot
of uh that's true you're gonna be that
comic who rocks a suit on the road
oh yeah that's a lot you gotta iron it
you gotta steam it and then the suit
that cut can go out of style so now you
gotta buy a new suit
do you think yeah i guess slim fit at
some point i'll probably go back to
baggy
probably yeah i was complaining about
like fashion is so weird man i hate
fashion
i hate it like i bought those underwear
gap recently and it's it's over the top
i was complaining about it it drove me
nuts
what do you mean over the top it's no
fly oh a lot of underwear is no fly now
they're like you go over the roof you
don't go through the window and they go
the window
is the most important part it's all
about the window
roof what are we doing oh now we're the
weird kid at the the the school bathroom
was pulling the pants all the way down
yeah that's a weird kid yeah you don't
want to walk through a urinal and see
butt cheeks
oh that's a bad luck i know and it's
weird because old people do it too
so it's weird how it just you start out
doing it then you live your whole life
pulling it through the window and then
when you get old again you just drop
them down again
this is weird it's kind of like diapers
you know what my bit of peeve is
when we don't have a a green room uh
bathroom
and i'm fine look i'll find pissing with
everybody but the the
the chatterbox at the urn ah dude
never fails they go up oh oh
sam what's up oh my god i can't believe
i'm peeing next to sam morrell or
even if they're just even if they don't
know you either even if they're just
like
so uh good night huh it was
yeah yeah what do you say and you better
pray to god as a partition
oh god please i have a theory yeah
racially mixed cities have partitions
because i don't think though the honky
wants to be urinating
and have the giant black dong with the
partition he feels
comfortable but then i go to like you
know appleton wisconsin where it's all
white no partition
interesting that's a theory it also just
could be it's more it's a more
progressive place so they're just like
you know we got to be on this right
right right we don't want any harassment
or whatever i'm a fan of the partition
love the parts i don't think we need to
i don't think we need to be like just
looking at a bunch of dicks
yeah i mean no partition is one step
away from the trough
the trough is garbage well that's a
tough moment for whatever
why not just piss on the street at that
point i know what are we in calcutta
come on it is fun when they put the ice
in it though you gotta admit
oh my god i feel like a superhero i'm
like [ __ ] you ice
yeah that was a big chunk i just took
down
yeah uh wait what were we talking about
urinals partitions suits
oh [ __ ] oh i want to give a toast to
speaking about airport pissing
love a toast toast this is like the
anti-peas yes
exactly you gave a peep i'm gonna give
it a toast
i got of the united lounge i'm toasting
airport lounges it was a game changer oh
my god
what a what a moment i love it i love an
airport lounge
ah milestone you just get just pay for
the
lounge with delta just do it it's funny
i was talking to my account money guy
our money guy
and he was like you got to get more
credit cards because i have one credit
card
i hate credit as we know as you yeah
wait i thought you didn't have a credit
card well i have one but i keep it in a
drawer in you know new orleans
it's far away i don't understand i just
don't trust myself i don't like the idea
that i can swipe this and just buy
[ __ ] that's not paid for i got to pay
for it later it's too risky no i
understand the mindset but like
you just don't be an animal with it yeah
yeah
i don't know it's it's like like if i
owe you money you're like hey i got this
i'm like i'll just pay you right now i
just want to go on that way too but also
yeah i don't i mean like you get [ __ ]
out of you get like rewards and
stuff that's why i do it yeah that's
what he said so
so i'm gonna get the delta one it's all
dude the delta one's great yeah i'm
gonna do it now
now for the first time my life i'm
waiting for one of those ladies you know
behind the little desk with the
tablecloth going i got the delta who
wants the delta card everybody goes ah
blow me
now i need that lady i love that lady
yeah i don't know where else to get one
it's great and it's also i just like the
lounge man it's like that is like
luck so many times just like unless you
just save dough
and yes save dough because you don't
have to buy like a 12
egg sandwich that sucks so true and you
kind of get there early and usually it's
like ah
i got 45 minutes to kill before this and
now i'm in the lounge and i'm like i
only have 45 minutes
ah i know yeah you want to you want to
get you can get work done yeah you get a
you get some food you have a coffee you
have a
cocktail i know open bar the food was
great it's open bar is it
the united was i don't think delta oh
interesting i think they charge you
damn that's shocking it is shocking it's
an outrage i say
it is no uh it really uh it's pretty
great and i'd like that
i mean it's such a stressful experience
traveling like i've had three travel
days in a row
especially when you don't feel well
you're just like [ __ ] i just want to
just not be stressed and that lounge is
is
key i'm impressed man that's uh that's
that's impressive stuff to just bounce
around like that it's so hard on the
body it's hard on the sleep schedule i'm
hurting
yeah yeah you're here same but it's a
job man i mean i love our job so it's
nice i
do it's just a good like i was in albany
all weekend with uh you know dina hashem
and uh
and uh shafi hussain and we had a good
time and we're uh
delia you guys got the whole middle east
on this show
what is he he's indian yeah and then
she's muslim
yeah what is she where's she her people
from
she's from jersey i don't know where
where exactly her uh
and then a new york jew it's just a fun
little gaza
going on oh yeah we got we got she
mentioned it and i was like you know
what i didn't even see it to you
mentioned
i'm that progressive yeah you know uh
yeah we had a great time man it's funny
like i hadn't been to the albany funny
bone
uh in a while in like years and it's
like i was like man why
i guess small comedy shows aren't that
bad it's like oh it was just people came
out
yes last time i was there like it was
just papered
free tickets no one's paying attention
they're on their phone
it's funny because all you need is a
room with a microphone
and chairs and we've always had papered
rooms when it's your people
that any room could be good i mean if
it's not a million
mile high ceiling and [ __ ] like that
yeah it was good man where where you
were virginia beach virginia beach which
is a notoriously tough room
and but it was our people so and they
were great
and the setup was good setup's good it's
a small club
and they have a kind of like a little
balcony and it's like
it's like a 2004 museum in virginia
beach like everybody's got afflicted
shirts a drinking monster
you know they've got big trucks it's so
behind you know baggy pants
and a chain wallet and jeans shoes
michael richards hasn't even been
canceled yet
yeah yeah exactly i was like the friends
were
like we're still on friends i don't even
know about the reunion
so it's kind of wild to go there and
it's an hour flight it's like a
40-minute flight
did you ever watch friends i did i
watched it every day i hated it
i hated it too but i kept watching it it
was on it was familiar they were
attractive
it was new york it was they were
attractive chandler was funny
he's a great comic actor he is and so
lisa cooter is a great comic actor too
yeah but it's just you're right it's
just not not good
there's so many wild premises she's like
half
like half a [ __ ] uh joey's really stupid
you know it's so weird yeah but they're
friends and they had a huge apartment
rachel's works at a coffee shop
none of it makes sense but if you just
create a show where like there's a bunch
of good-looking people that like will
they won't they hook up
yes people will watch it that's so true
yeah
i mean they had to flip-flop with joey
hooked up with
phoebe at one point monica and chandler
ross rachel and joey and rachel it just
it would you know what it was
it was like you could tell everything
about a person if they thought that show
was better than seinfeld because it was
friends versus seinfeld
boy that is so true it was like if you
thought friends was better than seinfeld
you weren't funny
i was my roommate in college was dating
this super hot like bimbo girl
and she was like i don't like seinfeld
and this is you know this is 2002.
i was like you don't like seinfeld and
she's like no no i like friends i was
like why she goes because they're better
looking and i was like
wow you are so vapid that you would say
that out loud
that's a great uh that's a great
takeaway jason alexander's know matt
leblanc
that's your that's your observation i
know it's like seinfeld and larry damon
at the helm
with michael richards doing his amazing
physical comedy and
oh come on yeah it's you know what my
wreck is this week and this is a good
segue for this
frasier oh great wreck we were talking
about this it's on hulu
i was on a flight great a long flight
and i was just kind of burnt out
you know my knicks had just been
embarrassed and they're
gone now or whatever but uh i was in a
bad mood i'm like what can i watch it'll
like
wash the tears away and i just throw a
fraser on i watch the pilot is
incredible
oh it's an incredible pilot it's just
like first off i love the idea that
these two
these two like what are they british and
their dad's like an old irish cop
it makes no sense right yeah they're so
highfalutin they're so high society they
speak like british people
yeah that is true yeah what is that i
don't know
i guess they're trying to show like look
how rich we are we're so rich we're
british
[Music]
they're so theatery yeah and the dad is
like i'm just gonna watch the game
look at her father how could you yeah
right
and then daphne was british she's
australian i don't know she's from
manchester
united you know what's funny is uh it's
so much
i like it's such a good escapist show
because there are no real steaks
yeah every episode is like frasier's
dinner party gets ruined
right right and it's very light like
even if something horrible happens the
dog comes in and makes a face
so yeah i like that show i went to a
live taping once
when i was a kid we did like a family
vacation my dad had a business trip in
l.a and he's like i'll just turn this
into a family vacation
and that was like the highlight i've
never seen it
and i saw it live and i was like [ __ ]
kelsey grammer live oh man that guy's
like on another level he's a presence
the booming voice he's so big
man that's how cool was that incredible
and he was i think he was
just sober like i mean that was the
first few seasons of that show he was a
drug addict
yeah dude i didn't know dude he has had
like the worst life of anyone i've ever
seen is that right
his [ __ ] dad and sister were murdered
yeah isn't that crazy yeah where are
they from
i don't remember but you know then i
think he just developed this
he never dealt with anything he just it
was this great actor and developed his
drug problem
wow and they said the whole cast was
like giving him interventions and stuff
and they're like they cared about him
they knew he was a good person wow
that's kind of cool to hear that he
because you think like oh this guy's an
actor he's a blowhard he can't stop
drinking like get it together man but
no he's got people people have real [ __ ]
yeah holy hell
and it's so funny to have this murder
guy's dad and
sister murdered and he's playing this
highfalutin guy it's like yeah that's
acting that's
acting baby but he dude he's so it's
really just
killer yeah killer pilot great idea so
many jokes
yeah and it was in seattle which was
weird i thought as a kid i was like
seattle what's up with seattle you know
that was back before you knew everything
about every town because we didn't go
there
yeah oh now we know too much too much
and we know the deep
dark secrets like seattle the heroin
epidemic you know the hipsters
yeah [ __ ] oh that's a good wreck
hard wreck hulu it's it's just it's just
good
it's good it's light it's theatery which
is kind of
yes it's almost like neil simon it is
like neil science it's not
like many sitcoms you see anymore right
right and
a rare spin-off success yes you know
it's a cheer spin-off and it worked
yeah but i'm sure that chick she's like
i don't like frasier they're not good
looking enough
i know she's like he's balding you know
what's hilarious they do look like
brothers
yeah they kind of do they kind of do
they have that
aryan white face there's a whole episode
how they're like competing who gets to
be corkmaster in their wine club like i
love shows where the steaks are just so
stupid yeah well like this doesn't
matter at all to me
but i'm it's just funny so you don't
give a [ __ ] that's funny yeah they're at
the opera they're the symphony it was
always high-end [ __ ]
yeah all right my wreck you're not gonna
like it that's a little controversial
all right i mean why am i not gonna like
mineconf
[Laughter]
so we've been on the road a million
years you got i had to get up at a
5 45 for my flight today and then you're
in a virginia beach or an oklahoma town
or in nebraska and you have to get an
uber to get to the airport
yeah so sometimes you're like uh i'm up
at 5 45
i got to be at the airport at 6 30. i'll
get an uber
uber 28 minutes you know because it's
these weird towns unacceptable
i didn't even realize it umar khan my my
host for the weekend
i just met him great guy arlington
virginia pakistani part of the middle
east your whole thing
and he could be part of my tour yeah he
did a guest set on my show because
uh the knicks game was on and i i wanted
to start let me start 15 minutes late
and then i threw him up for 15 because i
want to catch the ending
how funny is the one game we won hey
there you go
yeah he told me about that he's like hey
let me do time because your knicks are
on like yeah good you should follow him
in the nixar season
but uh yeah the name of that tour could
be something with bombing
all right but
so he told me hey you know you can
schedule an uber oh wow i was like what
do you mean he's like you can just
schedule one when it
you know comes out like when you when
you want one it'll pick you up if you do
it ahead of time you can just
pay extra for this no wow so i just get
i've been
so many mornings pulling my hair out
sweating looking at the clock i wake up
extra early i didn't know about this
exactly so uber schedule it's got a
little clock on there you just push the
clock and you pick the time you want
boom haters won't do it but maybe
maybe yeah maybe if i'm in a weird city
but i'm i'm like i'm a yellow
cat man you know me yeah but what are
you going to call a yellow tail i'll
take them sometimes yeah no i'll take
them sometimes but because they're just
hard to find now and morning up
i have been taking uber's two airports
just because i can't rely on finding a
yellow cab when i'm in a rush
yeah yeah but i take yellow cabs back
always and they're less money too
they are now for sure so that brings me
to
my next point i got this download this
app called curb
like the tv show yeah and it it brings
it's like an uber for
the cabs it just says hey i need a cab
in in five minutes
here so you can just get a cab coming to
your house that's how i got here
cab it was a yellow cab but it was nine
dollars
and i looked at the uber and it was 19.
these [ __ ] are criminals
criminals
they know what they're doing really i
think we talked about this on the
patreon but uber really
i think they were operating at a loss
for like i think they're still operating
at a loss
you think i think there's some yeah i
think they're just i assume they were
huge they're global well they have uber
eats and every all these things right
but then uh you know lyft i feel like
lyft just came out and they're like
let's wait for uber to [ __ ] up
and they did yeah they did that ceo is a
real dick bag
that's right that's right so then lift
scooped in they were like we're the good
guys and you can tip our
drivers and we have better uh rates for
our employees and all that
and then they got two purple we're hip
yeah exactly we're a little gayer
and then they got too high up and uh
charged too much and now we're back to
caps you ever get in those lifts or
something you ever get in and they have
like the
little like screen on it like lift lift
yeah and then they have like candy in
the back
and you're like would that get picked up
by willy wonka here like what the hell
is happening
i know and there's purell there's candy
it says please tip
like all right i got it i got it i'm
still not gonna turn around is the
temperature okay
yes it's fine please right right there's
like eight chords for every
smartphone ever made like do you have a
nokia
yeah yeah there is something about the
lift though man where it's like
it does feel a little hipper but then
they had all these new ones they had
like uh [ __ ]
juno that one under i think oh yeah that
was quick juno was the hip one though
like
20 off every ride then i'm like yeah
you're not gonna last
right i tell you what is sexy though i
was with che once and he's like let's go
to a bar i was like
he's like i'll get an uber and he got
the uber black you know whatever
high end suv leather the uber white
yeah yeah that's true the uber white
trash
and the guy came out in a suit open the
door i was like damn
i'm used to the guy you know doesn't get
out he pops the trunk
there's a serious in the back she's just
rubbing you yeah yeah exactly
so that was nice but yeah uber yeah i've
done that once
that's funny that's that's a famous
person movie it's a famous or trying to
get laid move like you're going to date
get an uber black that really
up your chances yeah i was at amy's once
and and she called uh
an uber i was with rachel feinstein and
we just uh she was like okay i'll get
you i'm gonna call you an uber and we're
like uber black
yeah have you heard of uh this is more
of a car
thing what's that car one touro
it's airbnb for cars so basically some
guy
has a sweet ferrari or something
and if you go to nashville you can
touro his car and he's like left the key
on the tire
go by and you you get to the ferrari for
a day well how's this spelled
t-u-r-o t-u-r-o toro i mean am i ever
gonna do it i can't drive but
did you do it i did it once and it was
sexy i got this
crazy ass porsche what yeah are you did
you take pictures of this
i took i think i got some in here i
didn't want to take pics because it was
just me
so i didn't want to be like right you
know you could also you could just be
doing that in the street it's not that
cool
that's true how about those people
they're just like in front of a car
you're like that's not even your car not
even your car you're gonna do that
i know i used to do that too
with one of those cameras where you had
to go yeah yeah exactly i waited for
that photo to get developed
check me out in front of this [ __ ]
mercedes i'm like oh i can't i can't
actually drive and my friends know that
this might not work right yeah uh we've
all done it
we've all done it but it's a dick bag
move i've done that in front of women
i'm like
my friend takes a photo of me next to
some hot model
man this is pretty polish it off yeah it
goes down easy are you driving or no
no okay driving is he can he drive
oh yeah oh yeah i think just about
anybody can drive no offense
a lot of new yorkers are bad drivers i
heard colin quinn can't drive i've been
to college with dave patel he's not a
good driver
i've heard that i heard david tell us
terrifying he does both he looks like
he's driving a toy car
where he's got both hands i think he
just keeps doing this oh my god
it's very stressful he's from long
island yeah but he's not he's just not
you could just tell he's not a driver
he's a better driver than i am oh wow
like if we're if we're in a car together
like he should be driving i'm telling
you patreon a video of me
teaching you to drive a stick would be
gold we'll put some
some orange cones out get a few beers i
don't want to [ __ ] your car up there
well we get a rental we got a rental
all right we got a touro all right what
do you got on uh
on uh oh you did your p van wreck
yeah here's my peeve and this one's a
little
uh high concept so i hope i hope i
cleared to make this clear i was hanging
out with a bunch of people
and we're all they're all kind of
younger comics a lot of one-upping
you know which is already a lot you know
give me an example you know just like a
lot of like
trying to be funnier than everybody else
and no one's really listening to anyone
they're just trying to get their
laugh you know oh young comics are tough
man that anxiety and that need like
look we were looking
with nick griffin attel and you know
artie lange i want to get one in you
know
but you got to sit back and they don't
hate you if you sit back
yeah yeah so everybody's kind of being a
lot
and i'm just drinking it's like two
shows late we did two shows
i got a scotch you're doing a meet and
greet yeah it takes a lot out of you
exactly let's relax stop jumping in
that's why i love when there's a game on
i'm like let me just get the game on we
get zoned out a little
zone out and you talk when you need to
talk but you can still have something to
focus on
oh man it's the best it's the best yeah
so uh
i threw something out and i it had i
i couldn't think of the name of that
kind of sugar i think it's stevia
oh yeah is that something yeah yeah and
i was like what's that sugar called
you know it's like a little packet it's
not sugar it's fake sugar if you're like
equal i'm like no it's not equal and
they're like i don't think you know what
you're talking about man i'm like no no
and just because i couldn't think of the
name they assumed i didn't have their
they didn't exist
and it was driving me crazy it was like
a group of people shut this down
yeah no one even threw splenda at you
nothing or maybe they said split them i
said no i think it's something else it's
something else it's like fake sugar
it's better for you or whatever and
they're like ah you're crazy man i'm
like
what do you think i'm just making up
chemicals and so we got all into it and
then somebody i think later was like oh
i think you're talking about stevie and
i was like thank you
but i hate the idea of just because i
don't know the name all of a sudden
this thing doesn't exist and it drove me
crazy yeah it just doesn't feel good to
be dismissed either yeah
like just because you guys aren't
willing to go with me here then i'm
completely wrong i don't know
the whole thing bugged me then later i'm
like googling it like stevie
sucks does it yeah they would sell like
i think like like dwayne reed or those
drug stores they would sell like stevia
soda and i didn't know what it was
but so i bought it once thinking it was
like just salsa
then i drank it i'm like this tastes
like [ __ ] yeah yeah
i remember nutrasweet was big what's
that that was like equal
it's like fake sugar but it turned out
to be worse for you a lot of this [ __ ]
the impossible burger apparently is
worse for you is it that's what they
said some of them taste good though i
mean
i'm impressive and also it's like i
trust that [ __ ] more than i trust like a
chicken breast
at a mole comedy club i'm sorry i don't
like it it's all it all is i think bad
for you you know
yeah it's all chemicals it's all bad
yeah i mean they're all bad probably but
then uh
yeah those [ __ ] like those cookies with
health cookies my grandparents used to
eat them
they they'd have like a tray of like
cookies that would be like all snack
wells
that was big with the uh the florida
community yes
and they'd be like no fat but it's full
of sugar it's cool about everything else
snack wells is such a like great name
for you i know
i know all that [ __ ] like gluten-free
anything my ex was gluten-free and
everything had extra sugar because you
got to make up for the gluten
but isn't gluten like that's but that's
like a thing that you can't i mean
that's like inflammation or whatever
what is that celiac celiac but but
everything
to make the cookie still taste good you
had to put all the extra butter and all
this [ __ ] in it just to keep it good
right [ __ ] like vegan cookies yeah
people think you're eating vegan it's
just healthy but it's like you just
a lot of bad [ __ ] is still i know you
could still like there's a vegan place
right by here and it's like this [ __ ]
ain't healthy it ain't healthy
it's just not meat taste some of it
tastes good though but it's like
it's just yeah it's i mean people who
are vegan i know like
some of them i know some people people
were vegan do they never get sick
really a lot of pro athletes like kyrie
irving is vegan now and like
uh interesting it's interesting like
these guys because i think they just get
less inflammation ah right right
i gave up bread you never eat i've seen
you eat bread
ah [ __ ] well i i i cheat on their bread
every now and then but
every pizza i gave up pizza what and i
never have a bagel
i don't touch bagels look how angry i
got the chewing me just
bagels to me is a crazy meal it's just
so much dough it's so stupid
bread it's crazy that's that might be my
death row meal
a bagel with with uh with a smear
listen a bagel with a smear smoked
salmon onion tomato capers
that's a [ __ ] meal right there that
is nice but i get a bite or two of that
i can't do the whole roundy i mean my
friend i've never been to a bris
i'll tell you that's true i'd like to
have a good time no
what's your death throw meal then that's
a good ques i would go comfort food like
a pot roast a meatloaf a fried chicken
i like lasagna i like comfort diner food
is my favorite designer
is a good call yeah it's all horrible
for you but
man i love that chicken fried steak ah
the best
i went we were in arlington virginia
gary veeder and i and uh
we went we found a it's nothing like
finding a great diner on the road
the one that hasn't changed since 1941
no blacks
i mean the whole thing they don't let
anything it's the same griddle
it's the same counter it's the same
waitress flow she calls you hun
i love it it was it was a classic
uh it was just like a classic like great
like
it's funny how you eggs can just be
better yeah
it's like for some reason the omelette
was ten times better here we had another
place
uh that it was fine but i'm like this
this place
silver diner i think in arlington [ __ ]
it's great it's great like i'll go there
to one of those diner and you get the
uh what's the soup of the day oh we got
vegetable and and
and french i'm like give me the
vegetable and it's homemade vegetable
soup but i can't believe it like some
guy came in early made that [ __ ] he's
not but then isn't it crazy if you go to
a restaurant and they just dump a can
like that's crazy too kills me kills me
there's a lot of that too
that's crazy i know he's like why open a
restaurant
yeah right it's like a comic who steals
jokes like what what's your point of
view
you know this is tick-tock diner
that's great we have one of those there
is
34th street penn station not a great
diner not a great diner
expensive and shitty yep yep they get
the tourists i guess
coming out of penn station i've been
there it's like it's not horrible but
it's not like
it's not hard to make a good diner no no
how weak is that diner coffee i need
like four cups to feel like yes that's
so true
i like 7-eleven coffee you like it well
i like it i get it but i don't think i
like it i like
bodega coffee i like i like gas station
coffee
i like are you drinking it black oh yeah
i might put one of those little caps of
cream in
yeah but uh starbucks i hate starbucks i
i hate it but
it's grown on me now that they have some
oat milk i can just throw in there i
just
i just like oat milk i love oat milk i
can't believe people liked almond milk
it's [ __ ] bad is it once you have oat
milk like this shits
what's wrong with almond it's just not
as good
it's like i i like i like to see my
coffee change just
a little bit of color yeah i like this i
like to experience the color change
don't have to stir it just put a little
in there i'm i'm good
yeah okay i do odor whole i i don't want
i do hold two
half and half is fine yep yep i don't
like soy
sauce i hear it's bad for you here it's
camera is it bad for you
too yeah that's what i hear all this
[ __ ] all this new health [ __ ]
there's a reason stuff's been around
forever you know but it's scary when you
hear like the four food groups the food
pyramid the poop pyramid is [ __ ]
was the pyramid scheme it was yeah
exactly it was
it was like the government was like we
gotta push grain we need to help the
farmers so they put that in
and i know we're getting a conspiracy
[ __ ] but when you look at it this isn't
that dark there's a lot of conspiracy
talking true
i don't think anyone's like we got to
cancel them over the grain uh
the grain theory yeah there's no child
blood on the uh
food group but yeah yeah it's like all
this is horrible you know no
no one's no one's gonna trash the
capital over uh the food groups
uh anything when you look into it is
like almonds they say all
one almond takes 80 gallons of water
you're like what almond
i had a bag of all this today i just ate
like a lake
you know but it's all a bummer to look
like they're so satisfying during the
day but then
at night if you've had a few drinks it's
the least satisfying
thing of all time no fun with an almond
no fun give me an m
m with a peanut or something eminem
pretzel chips
yes oh chips it sucks how good chips are
they're so good what do you do i like
those kettle chips those uh oh yeah
there's really crunchy
what what's your go-to flavor i mean i'm
a [ __ ] i like dorito
really i love a classic dorito give me a
cool ranch a cheese
wow i'm so not and that i don't dislike
them but i'm like
all day i'm like give me those like
kettle chip salt and vinegar sour cream
and
oh that's good that's my oh dude korean
barbecue those
i love it i don't know if it made it up
here but we had zaps
and those are pretty damn those are
[ __ ] that's like a new orleans it's a
new orleans thing yeah they have
voodoo crawdad all these cool flavors
those are [ __ ] good
yeah that's good stuff those are those
are crunchy too i also do i like the
weird flavors i've had pickle flavored
chips
they're good i'm into that especially
you get a you get a flavored chip like a
pickle or a sour cream and you dip it in
a dip oh it's an explosion of of orgasm
in your
in your mouth and your pants dude it's
[ __ ] good i love it i like that i
like
um pringle yeah i like a pringle i don't
mind a pringle pink
pringles got a middle of the road
they're good yeah
they're not i mean the crunch is so it's
so big with a chip
yes and those and those kettle chips are
just game changers man
i love that [ __ ] sun chip yeah they're
pretty good and i love them
i don't like a chip that's trying to be
healthy sunshine feels like it's
pretentious to me it's like a bisexual
chick yes yes
sun chip what the hell's that mean the
out the sun sunshine like channing like
it's green
yeah yeah yeah we're fighting climate
change here at sunship
at a country salsa or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah exactly
zesty vegetable shut up get a job
vegetable chips yeah what are we doing
with
vegetable chips i know i'm already
eating a chip
at restaurants sometimes they'll do like
caroline's comedy club used to do this
those zucchini chips oh
nice little yogurts those are good yeah
yeah
i love a uh man yeah how about in canada
when they do like ketchup potato chips
yeah that's [ __ ] weird get out of
here canada throw a pear
ketchup you're not doing much for your
rep as having the shittiest palate
of any country i know jesus christ
poutine is overrated i'm sorry
it's all right it's all right it's disco
fries with cheese curd get out of here
yeah they're going i'm more if we're
doing cheese fries i want it melted i
don't want just like chunks of cheese
yeah right exactly i want like i want
some like cheddar american on that [ __ ]
don't ever get pizza in canada by the
way is it terrible it's almost like
montreal has good pizza do they yeah
yeah okay well
you get like i'm talking about like a
pizza stand maybe you go to a nice
restaurant i'm sure they have some
decent pizza but if you go to like a
pizza stand at one in the morning it's
like
it's almost like if an alien was told
what pizza was they're like okay i'll
try to make that
it's got no love in it it's got no
cheese
pull it's got nothing interesting yeah
it's that's
yeah i guess it's not montreal it's i
guess it's about the
the bread and like montreal does have
pretty good bagels too oh yeah i like a
montreal bagel
that's true but uh you're right yeah
overall it's not great
yeah interesting on the uh death row
meal
they also do lay's potato chips that are
like chocolate there have you seen those
in canada
no chocolate potato chips it's a lot
yeah
come on i mean look who's talking like
we have the double down the kfc bowl
the choco taco choco taco is [ __ ]
good
so good that's like that's like first
time high meal yeah
you gotta you're high for the first time
you get either like a choco taco or like
a
a snickers ice cream bar oh my god the
snickers ice cream bar is like your
first
time you get your ass eaten that thing
is insane
oh matt perked up on that one how about
the twix ice cream bar i've never had it
it might be even better
what see twix now here this is where i
got another secret to unleash
i don't love hard foods really like a
biscotti
or a crouton it's too hard for me and
twix can be a little too hard
i like twix a lot of everybody likes
twix what's your go-to if you're doing a
candy bar what are you doing i think
snickers is up there
yeah i know it's basic and and basically
it's like that's like liking regular m
ms it is a little basic it's a little
bit i think my all-time favorite is the
the reese's cup yeah that's a good one
you told me that actually
i love i love anything with peanut
butter in it do you do you
uh gummy ever like uh like twizzler or
sour patch kids or something
that's child's play come on that i don't
even know what a twizzler is it's like
rubbery
and gelatiny really there's no flavor
when we were kids like playing
baseball we'd be on the side like bite
off each side except your gatorade
through that we did not win a lot of
games
you got diabetes though you played one
school with our teacher
uh their principal was uh thrown out for
molesting kids and i started a china
game
hey teacher leave those kids alone and
we just kept chanting that and they were
just like oh
you guys hilarious and they beat us but
we you know we got digs in
yeah you're looking at him with the
twizzler
oh man you're the catcher again huh
uh interesting i like a twizzler yeah
yeah i just i got black licorice would
you ever do that oh
no no i don't know good black licorice
is pretty i've never had good black
licorice but yeah it's
i don't know i don't get any of the it's
just chewy and
rubbery and weird to me i don't know so
you're a big you're a chocolate guy
chocolate guy all the way i'm not even a
big
fruity candy guy yeah it's risky yeah
like all my friends like gummy bears all
day i'm like i can have two gummy bears
doesn't do it sweet tarts get out of
here
are just like who is that that's like
who's your audience i feel like like
skaters or something
yeah you can have a surge surge
do you ever drink surge oh yeah i mean i
was a skateboarder
we were dumb yes i feel like we're uh
we're dating ourselves here yeah for
sure
all that [ __ ] crystal pepsi azima
all gone crystal pepsi so it was white
pepsi
it was just clear pepsi yeah clear not
white i don't have to make everything a
racial issue on this podcast
this pepsi is white yeah i saw a guy at
the comedy club he was yelling at his
girlfriend he was being like verbally
abusive and then he ordered a girly
drink which made me laugh
it's like shut up ho uh lemon drop
please
[Laughter]
don't you kind of lose a little respect
when
uh somebody has to have a sugary drink
you're like you don't know how to drink
of course it's like when i see people
put too much sugar in your in their
coffee i'm like
you should have just gotten like a
milkshake i know right you want a coffee
and you do that every day
yeah it's weird like uh sugary cocktails
i
i get if you have like one or two but if
you can like they're people that get
like [ __ ] up off just sugary kind of
like you must feel
horrible horrible horrible yeah that
that crash from the sugar
electric lemonade you got [ __ ] up off
blue drinks
i know i know and then also like you're
a grown up at what point do you go like
i gotta kick this
[ __ ] but it tastes good yeah i know but
so does uh
candy but you just can't eat candy all
day every day i like this idea of an
intervention you have a problem
drinking no you're a [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] you drink like a [ __ ] yeah
be a man uh my girl likes a big stout
[ __ ] guinness you know all kinds of
lagers and [ __ ] i'm like i love that
yeah i'll do sugar in my drinks which
would be like a cool cocktail like in
manhattan or
negroni or something yeah but at least
that has some
subtle integrity to it you know it's got
some uh
class yeah it does get [ __ ] up off
only manhattan's or negroni's you're
gonna feel that the next day oh yeah oh
for sure i got these really good glasses
at home that our boy phil hanley got me
and they're like
like they just make something about a
good glass it just makes the drinking
experience so much better
so true good glass and that i got that
ice cube ball and this that goes a long
way
game changer yeah you just it just makes
you appreciate it it makes you like kind
of nurse it a little more it makes you
but like you have a nice glass even like
you're drinking wine out of like like
you know when you're a kid you're
drinking you'll drink wine or whatever
out of a
like a dixie cup or something oh yeah
but then you haven't had a real glass
and you're just like i'm like i'm an
adult
yeah there's something out of glass like
you know you go to a baseball game and
they give you a cup of
beer in a plastic cup you're kind of
like all right all right but then you go
to a bar you have like pint glass it
just feels better
although there's something about like i
know that they have like a reason for
this but when you get a beer and like
too fancy a glass i'm kind of like
slow down i'm with you on that like the
who am i the ladies man
[ __ ] leon phelps i'm swirling it like
it's cavazier right the snifter what is
that beer the duvel or whatever yeah
yeah it tastes good but like are we
really i'm with you
it's not it's not like i know it's like
a good beer right like i accepted it but
i'm just maybe i'm just not a beer guy
oh interesting i mean i like beer but i
just don't think i'm like blown away by
like the fancy years
yes delirium tremor that's pretty good
that's good that's a good beer
but then they're like it has to breathe
in this cup you're like i'm out i don't
need to breathe
come on just give me the beer how do you
feel about a sour beer
i can have half of one it's too much for
me
i had i had a sour monkey in la had a
few of those while watching the game
they're pretty good
okay yeah that's to me that's not like
uh we're going we're going out tonight
beer i'm like that's a watch tv
or sit in the park beer can you get
drunk on guinness or is it too thick
dude i went to ireland for that comedy
festival
i was with you oh yeah the vodafone yeah
yeah sorry we had a great time
i was drunk the whole time what a great
crew me
you rachel chris d colin quinn napa
godzilla nate pargotzi just the best
crew
and sean padden sean pat nick vadarat
yeah tj miller we're all at this crazy
old you know
1820 bar and we're on the third floor
they're all
oh oh oh you know jumping up the place
this place is shaking the floor is
creaking
and they were like it's last call so
vadarot put his credit card down and
ordered
every like he's like give me 40
guinnesses so the guy's just like i have
a photo of it
guys just doing this doing this there's
40 guinness pints on the table and we
finished them all and i don't remember
the night i don't know how i got home
my ass hurt when i woke up it was a hell
of a night and the guinnesses are smooth
they are really good there so good why
are they so much better there why can't
we recreate that flavor i don't know
what are we doing here
we got a honda plant we could remake a
honda you know it is annoying when
people are like you should it's like it
is like the
same person who's like the book was
better yeah that's true
when they tell you how much better the
guinnesses oversee we get it
but like why can't we make it as good
yeah yeah i don't know
i don't know it's i think it goes back
to the the diner or the comfort food
or the pizza place this you gotta know
what you're doing it's gotta be that old
fat italian guy with the you know
stained t-shirt stains are big man oh
[ __ ] you know what i got
i had the the gnats in my drink
yesterday so gross ah
i hate that i didn't realize i mean i
had like three of them and then i'm with
dina and she's like there are bugs in
our drink and i was like
i've had like four of these cool uh but
it's like yeah it's the limes they're
all over those [ __ ] lines ah the
limes yeah the summertime the nats come
out i have these sticky things in my
apartment that catch them all it's a
nightmare [ __ ] gross but yeah you
the the gnats you can just pull them out
with your finger at least but still
still gross pulling bugs out of my drink
does she drink yeah oh that's fun okay
always good to have a feature that
drinks with you
yeah no she drinks all right well i
can't imagine dina hammered
she just like likes just like slows down
a little bit like most
slows down she's all right yeah like
slower
you know drinkers you know they just
kind of like she's like a chill drinker
all right all right she's not hurling
slurs or she does that but it's a very
calm energy
so it's nice grabbing a cop's gun
that's fun all right good for her should
we do bits how much time do you have
oh yeah yeah we got a few minutes let's
do some bits
is is he picking you up here no i'm
gonna i'm gonna uber down
it's not far all right um you wanna do a
bit or should i do a bit
hit me hit me has this been done this i
feel like i
can't believe it if this hasn't been
done but uh i have a whole thing about
how people think body cams are going to
stop police brutality it's like have you
never seen the show cops
right right like it's like they were
doing a lot of police brutality uh that
was pretty much the whole show
yeah to the point they like throw a dude
onto a car and they'd be like [ __ ] they
do not
let's take that again i'll throw them
again oh that's good i wanna do a thing
about how police brutality
is like uh it's like the show full house
like we know it's bad now right but in
the 90s would be like gather round it's
time to watch
oh yeah interesting because that show
was on the air for
33 seasons what cops
whoa 33 it's like it's like almost it's
been on longer than law and order
yeah wow a scripted cop show that we're
like this has been on a little long
yeah right right i mean i love cops we'd
watch with the family it was
it was part of the night i know it was
part of the schedule i never
i never liked it oh my god it was just
so fascinating
um and it was you know pre-internet clip
videos so it was like whoa you're seeing
real [ __ ]
now this world star and all that but it
was very manipulative i mean even the
intro
bad boy bad boy we're like all right the
cops are the good guys
and there was some shot and freud not
sean for but you compare like wow at
least we're not them i know he's not
that fat lady in the trailer
that really was like we act like reality
tv came out of nowhere but that was
reality tv
oh yeah real world all that [ __ ] that
was around for a while
real world yeah did you watch that [ __ ]
i did i loved it
it's crazy yeah but cops it's so true
with the body cam we're like we're gonna
get them
and then they had a show cop but they
could edit cops you can't edit a body
cam
that's true you could edit the tv show
you know
yeah and there's commercials that's what
body cam uh
you don't get you don't always get to
look you can't add music
yeah right you can't add snappy rapes
hold on
bad boys bad boys what you're gonna do
what you're gonna do
right right and there was cops you
watching with your family there was a
commercial you know for pizza hut in in
between
segments true uh i like the idea that
you can edit
yeah that's something yeah yeah it's
kind of like saying
hey we can't let donald trump tweet but
he's still the president
you know it's like you're worried about
this he's still
he's still in control yeah
there's an analogy there right you know
so trump is off
facebook until 2023. my first thought
was
just in time to run yeah
yeah there's something there what do you
got um this could be silly i'm trying to
my material is pretty dark at the moment
you told me i want to see it
it's dark and so i'm trying to like let
me get some clean stuff just in case you
need a tv
set or a seinfeld opening so you want
some clean ready at the
at the ham the helm at the helm yeah
yeah
so uh i've been hanging out with this
cat
that the lady got and i'm getting to
know the cat
and i talk about how the cat just stares
out the window all day and for the cat
the window is kind of like the cat's
phone
you know it stares out the window it
judges people or it stares at it all day
judging people with picking fights that
aren't real
then it catches a glimpse a reflection
of itself hates that guy
and then then the big ending is then he
sees
a female kitten he's like ooh or a
female cat then he's like oh i shouldn't
it's a kitten
it's hairless
[Laughter]
yeah that hits but it's kind of a long
way to go to get to that there's
something funny about like how
looking out the window just seeing like
the idea that you're on social media and
you just see people with better lives
[ __ ] look at this dog that's good yeah
he's living
he's living meanwhile the dog's homeless
but you just think they're doing better
than you
i mean that's what social media is yeah
you're just watching people with like
at their best exactly right yeah like
they're in cabo they're not showing you
leaving the [ __ ] abortion clinic
you know it's like uh i'm in i'm on
vacation right or finding a dinner or
not getting it up at that uh the bedroom
yeah that's true you never see a like a
picture of a guy just like this
what do you want yeah where should we
eat
i don't care
are you pissed i'm not pissed all right
the cat
the window is like yeah that's his phone
that's his phone
all day staring at it and there's
something about catching the glimpse
of the selfie oh sorry yeah oh no you're
on your phone
he's looking out the window you're both
avoiding your lives oh
that's good that's good yeah yeah
he's got to go to the vet but he won't
stop looking at the window and then i
talk about how he's a pill head he
sleeps all day and then when you try to
bond with him he cuts you
that part's hitting and then i have cats
are [ __ ]
fun man they're fun there's a lot of
material there and then the big
big ending is uh my girl wants another
one she's like we should get another cat
i'm like no no no you gotta catch like
abortions one or two is fine but after
about 12
people start judging i have a joke where
i say 12 abortions
11 11. we're good all right all right
baker's dozen
uh interesting man yeah that's uh that's
funny man
wait what's the twelve i'm now i'm
curious about the twelve jokes like the
apostles i say
think you're really progressive and then
you and then you uh talk to someone
who's
really progressive and you're like maybe
i'm not like i was talking to a guy who
said i think a woman should be able to
get 12 abortions if she wants and i was
like 12.
uh that's a that's a pretty uh
horrifying number to toss out there
yeah like you know like like it's not
affecting her day to day
once you hit the baker's dozen like once
you once you've killed enough fetuses
that they could have formed a band
ah uh ironically also called the
grateful dead oh
i know it was good yeah that's a great
one yeah i go with 12
too 12 is a fun number 12 number drowned
apostles
yeah it's it's one syllable too which is
nice 12.
but it's still a high number double
digits i'll go 11.
go 11 baby all right all right you can
go 12 i think we're fine ah that's a
totally different bit
but yeah i do i think uh what are we
talking about oh
we should we should tell people we got
uh we got our samples
oh that's right so next episode after
this
we it our booze of choice will be our
booze that we're gonna make
we're bringing in seven different
samples we got canadian whiskey
we got [ __ ] rye we got part rye part
bourbon
we got a lot of samples we're going to
sample them
here we're going to take sips i don't
know how we do this do we take a cracker
in between to cleanse the palate what do
we do
that's a good question yeah maybe we eat
a licorice or something just a licorice
yeah just to give you your i think that
will hurt your taste oh yeah you're
probably right well some kind of
ginger like in the sushi you need a
palate cleanser you know
maybe we just have a sip of water all
right a sip of water works and then we
uh
yeah so we'll sample that we'll come up
with what is going to be detour or fat
cat or whatever we end up calling this
long goodbye whatever we end up calling
right right yeah roadkill yes we don't
know we're calling our booze yet but
it's coming baby
you got i can't believe wheels are in
motion we got to thank christopher or
chris christopher
christopher hart christopher hart yeah
he's a booze booze aficionado down in
texas
he's helping us out so yeah thanks
christopher
we're gonna do it right in front of your
very eyes we're gonna pick it
this might be a record-breaking burp
episode the sample one for you
oh yeah oh yeah i'll be burping up
whiskey all day
so check it out give us your feedback
your input we want to know what you
think
and uh yeah we're gonna we're gonna make
a goddamn
booze to sell subscribe to patreon are
you where are you gonna be on the road
just so this is next week uh
that's a good question i'm in orlando
this weekend so that's gone
but uh never done the orlando improv
have you no
san antonio at the rock box nice uh
houston improv
funny bone serious toledo funny bone
philly helium that'll sell buffalo
dayton
appleton arlington albany so yeah fun
stuff
i got uh tampa side splitters raleigh
cincinnati funny bone oh man these are
fun rooms
um what else uh oh you did you're doing
the liberty
yeah you signed on i think so all right
okc
madison nashville
wow samurai.com shows
let's [ __ ] let's let's do it that's a
hot hot tour madison
to to nashville's up i think madison okc
nashville oh okc should be fun right is
that bricktown yeah oh that's a great
car here is great
great room i wonder how i sell in there
that could be a weird market
i don't think there's much to do out
there let's go yeah let's bet on that
no oklahoma is kind of cool man i played
tulsa with uh
i did tulsa with aziz once and it was
such a [ __ ] fun city mm-hmm
it's all these sleeper cities that don't
get their due but they're great tulsa is
like low-key like kind of cool
yeah i mean you know what i'm going to
give a peeve of myself i don't like
people using the word low-key i don't
know i just
it's overused it's not i'm mad at myself
for saying it just now
i i'm with the low key that's why i say
sneaky it's a sneaky cool town
sneaky's low-key but like you know it's
a little less [ __ ]
sneaky is oh it's better to be a low-key
guy than a sneaky guy oh that's true
that's true but like you got that guy's
sneaky hot
it's better than like guys low-key hot
yeah low-key is annoying yeah
it's just it's a lot of high-key [ __ ]
that people are saying right
like he's a little low-key like that's
it's very known
yeah new york's a low-key kind of cool
place is it
it's not local it's a big apple it's not
low-key yeah by the way i think that's a
greek god too
loki i think
matt give that a [ __ ] no loki you
[ __ ] there's a disney plus show
coming out he's one of them
not one loki nothing tom hiddleston
no never heard of him i don't want to
know all right i'm trying to keep
avengers out of my brain
too much marvel too much marvel yeah god
[ __ ] the monopoly i know
give me an original picture it's funny
marvel went like this
is so much about like just you know
anything in entertainment how they went
from bankrupt
to too much yeah i remember the 90s
they're like marvel has no money i'm
like it's spider-man how do they have no
money
like how badly did you mismanage [ __ ] i
know that's so true
and now it's just like there's gonna be
a spider-man movie every three years and
you're like well it's gonna be a new
story they're like no
it's the same movie yep maybe a
different it's like how many times do we
need that green
goblin story i know jesus christ we got
it
i hear toby mcguire is a [ __ ] monster
by the way i've heard the same thing did
you see that
um [ __ ] that aaron sorkin movie molly's
game
oh no i didn't see that it's pretty good
with jessica chastain
yeah but there's a guy michael sarah
plays this guy like player x in the
poker game and he's like a monster he's
like such a bad dude and i was like who
is it because it's a celebrity i'm like
who is this guy yeah
all the reddit boards were like toby
maguire
so he's like a dark poking poker play
and uh
yeah wow who knew toby mcguire is a
sneaky dark
there you go yeah i believe it there's
all kinds of you hear all kinds of guys
or douchebags out there
sometimes i've noticed if we're getting
a little bit of a little little
heat going and we start selling out and
then if you're not the nicest guy
ever at the club people think you're an
[ __ ] and you're like i just didn't
want to talk to you
at the urinal so now i'm a dark you know
right do you find that
not really all right i don't i mean i
get what you mean but i i'm sick of the
[ __ ] just get us a bathroom so i can
focus on the set
i know i know most clubs have it that's
true
all right all right i just get nervous
before i kind of be i'm in my head i
just want to like go over notes and [ __ ]
same then some guys got you in a
headlock at the you know
i do not care about the touching do you
ever get someone after like touched your
chest a lot
oh yeah like well can we just keep our
are we not a civilized society
i know i know i'm like the clown of the
show but like i had a guy going like can
i get a photo i was like sure and he's
like okay and he like moved me around
and i was like what are you doing you're
moving
like they touch your belly or something
i'm just like what is going on
i know that's a problem but hey
can't complain we're doing what we love
to do it's a problem
get on the patreon check us out it's
gonna be on uh it's gonna be on msnbc
later it's a big problem
someone touching mark's midsection yeah
i'm moving around
i don't love it it's a peeve this is one
i get all the time i thought you'd be
taller yeah we all did
thank you i'm 5 10. i it sucks all right
have a good night folks subscribe to the
patreon we'll see you soon
love it comedy